m
eh bien nous sommes en effet ce sens
avec le public de guingamp
bonsoir mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs regardé la foule qui est venue
très nombreuse pour participer à nos
jeux de 20 heures
alors je vais demander à nos amis
bretons êtes vous prêt à la rentrée
teisseire nous a fait voir cette foule
nombreuse et maintenant eh bien on va
vous montrer on va vous présenter
quelques images de la ville de guingamp
pour mieux connaître cette charmante
ville de bretagne
alors andré c'est parti yang en petite
ville tranquille de 10000 habitants
marché important et central y colle la
ville s'est développée autour de la
place du centre de la cité flow dal dont
il reste encore quelques vestiges
à voir également la populaire fontaine
dite la plomée fontaine à 3 vasques en
pierre et en plomb qui datent de la
renaissance ainsi que quelques vieilles
maisons anciennes la basilique notre
dame de bonsecours présente la
caractéristique d'être éco tic du côté
gauche et renaissance du côté droit
de nombreux édifices religieux et
profanes parsèment la région ainsi
l'abbaye sainte croix et le moulin de
salles pays de mission et de pèlerinage
on trouve encore à guingamp une vierge
noire dans la basilique notre dame
warren est maintenant eh bien nous
allons
les demoiselles brigitte le pape bonsoir
soit alors nous avait apporté un objet
un petit peu bizarre il va se détacher
balancez votre chemisier un peu blanc
voilà je tourne comme ceci pour qu'on
voit bien voilà et on va demander aux
invités de notre ami a relooké de
découvrir qu'elle était l'utilisation
précise de cet objet bien compris harold
vous avez parfaitement bien parler mon
cher jean pierre comme d'habitude ou
d'un groupe au grand complet et prêcher
découvrir cet objet mystérieux alors
allongé quel trou est-ce que ça à faire
avec la pêche n'ont pas digéré toutes
deux mois avec la poire non est-ce que
c'est utile c'est très utile
est ce que ça cache quelque chose
sainte-catherine gaza et exiger non plus
été aussi un des moyens moteurs non plus
sa carrière est-ce que ça cher pour
l'agriculture e on pourrait l'utiliser
en baisse en attendant on va bien vous
le présente des combats joie voyez très
important là il ya des trials
alternèrent et défendent des troupes des
bois greffant des fentes hui est ce que
ça c'est bon le cuir
non ça ne sert pas cool cuir pour le cru
est ce qu'elles s'assurent pour la
couture pour la cuisine pour la cuisine
pour la cuisine pour la limousine non
pas du tout pour moi et pour une chez
valve non plus pour la santé et pour la
maintenant les pendentifs des lyonnais
non on peut dire que cet objet date de
1902 1902 chirac avait deux ans non j'ai
pas trouvé trois ont suffi à la guerre
non pour la paix une arme de faire ça
n'aura jamais travaillé ou quelque chose
qu on ait envie de nous ça nous t'y de
travail donc pas pour l'agriculture
alors pourquoi pôle élevage pour les
bêtes pour la petite industrie non pour
le pour l'artisanat
oui mais voilà la question du fameux
stage s agit pas pour
où la couture et le tricot peu serrées
l'air pour le bois ne pour le poids
voilà non pas pour le fn
bon pour les os ou la faire fuir les
enfants pour le faire alors qu'est-ce
que alors pour la bijouterie noms
commencent à s'affoler les famines et
mes enfants
alors il nous faut une réponse j'ai
approché ut vous étonnez vous aimez bon
et semble en ne laissant pas les il a
évité aux notes récoltées la sacu placer
de brad n'est pas un casseur de gravats
d'un concasseur de bar admettent est
apparu dans la région 1902 c'est votre
dernière réponse
voilà c'est notre dernière c'est un
concasseur de bar admettent sur pierre
non eh bien je pense qu'on peut dire
mademoiselle brigitte le pape ont cet
objet bizarre oui nous allons faire la
démonstration maintenant avec cet outil
alors expliquez nous alors cet objet
servait à dévisser davis à tête fraiser
donc on placer la tête rasée dans les
dans les fentes et on serait donc et ont
dévissé
c'était pour récupérer les vis là
c'était pour récupérer les vices
sélectivement et qui a fabriqué cet
outil alors c'est monsieur boisard donc
en 1902 un qe2 à côté de guingamp saint
gildas des bois voilà
et bien bravo vous avez gagné 250 francs
pour le bureau notre social dans les
villes
non venez jouer juste et parfait tout à
fait remarquable ils n'ont pas trouvé et
je pense jean pierre que nous avons
notre ami lionel sur la sellette
montlaur à l'adjectif moi non mais c'est
prévu
oui un objectif et je vais dire chapeau
1 sylvie bravo on peut appeler sylvie
qui est notre candidat pour chapeauter à
balai vous allez poser des questions
pour découvrir un adjectif on connaît
bien ce jeu dans les jeux de 20 heures
alors à vous de jouer d'accord à les
premières questions
aimeriez vous habitez notre ville à
écouter moi j'aime bien guingamp j'aime
bien la bretagne messager bel20 si
j'habitais guingamp quettehou is rap
vise à nettoyer
parce que ça une importance considérable
qu'ils ont mais chaque chose dans son
place et puis qui ça bouge pas attention
un bien
accepteriez-vous de dîners six mois
écoutez d'abord vous êtes un père son
charmant mais si je vais manger chez
vous et il faut faire attention qu'est
ce qu'on va me donner à manger parce
qu'il y avait des choses kg/hl n y en a
deux choses que je n'aime pas et puis y
est voilà enfin je met d'accord je suis
allé à quelle heure je peux venir
tout à l'air bon vous me donnez leur
précis et si c'est assez normal car
maintenant quand je viens à -16 j'ai
bien peur qu elles ont des sports
aimez-vous j'aime les sports de fauteuil
quand je suis très bien si maintenant on
sait pas ça je vais dire et si on fait
les sports que moi j'ai fait il faut que
ce soit fait avec une heure
et je suis de tout que tout choix ya
tellement parfaite sans ça on ne peut
pas réussir qu'est ce que j'ai fait
comme sport m'assassine sport hamoir
aimez vous la plaisanterie
l'aqua la plaisanterie à écouter ça
c'est vraiment la dernière chose au
monde qu'il faut le faire avec moi parce
qu'elle ferait mention se permet avec
une plaisanterie dans le tac je suis et
si vous me regardez bien la figure comme
il est et bassins chance je l'accepterai
jamais pensez vous que jean pierre
descombes est à la hauteur pour exercer
son métier
pardon essais il est très bien mais
j'aime beaucoup mais il faut qu'avec moi
qu'il faut qu'il fait très très
attention parce que je surveille
absolument chaîne geste chaque minute
qu'est ce qu'il fait
voilà madame est ce que vous avez une
idée anthony nitia nous donne le début
de ce mot cinq ans par un ace madame s
comme suzanne avec onze lettres s11
l'être lionel ah oui il a un visage très
parlant notre ami lionel regardez le
bien là je suis lié au rapport
d'autopsié et ben bravo parce que
c'était pas facile rigide râble j'avoue
gagné 50 francs tous nos compliments
bravo j'en tiens vous avez été très bien
sur cette affaire et nous allons
maintenant demander une grande
championne elle est classée 1re série je
crois 15,2 dans le domaine des tic toc
avancé s'affilier à gaza ce type est un
pote on va donner un mot de cinq lettres
il faudra changer qu'une seule lettre
sans changer l'ordre bien sûr des autres
lettres du monde d'accord votre prénom
monsieur yan yan premier candidat avec
le mot anges
alors c'est en berne c'est monsieur qui
commence bougez bougez aux jeunes c'est
à sophie maintenant attention
un bus des loges à nouveau à sophie le
logis lesigne
c'est à vous monsieur logir bardot
maître capello lâchait hier j'ai eu hier
logis serait ce un néologisme stop
il vient de chez nous savons oui
monsieur d'idées louis n'a pas non plus
c'est bien tu es loin des leurs ce film
oui le loup des loups très fin très bien
les coups des corps car des corps et
décors bah oui mais pour faire quoi
la balle est dans votre camp
le pote et chez vous c'est jean binet
terminé bravo et bien c'est sophie qui
l'emportent qui a gagné cette première
manche où il se fit nous allons
continuer parce qu'elle est très très
fort bravo c'est fini maintenant à vous
nous changeons de mots saute so2 et en
os
ils ont fait ça vous mesdemoiselles met
bat ça va très vite la vie
allez sophie au filet 8 avantage une
petite culotte assez mal à l'aise dans
sa salle ici d'une chèvre entière
le bal cotte de maille noire en cote de
maille coûte goûter oui une pizza
cerutti alors oui c'est oui ouais voilà
la rue côté wool and cool vous voulez
vous pouvez
ah oui c'est bien cette poule sont forts
tout poil qui couve macoutes ne coupent
loupait pas très bien en août annonce
déjà été dit je crois dans la soupe à la
suite en brie sous toutes sortes forte
porte très bien
combats de géants combats de géants
bravo et payer bravo sophy nous allons
profiter parce qu'elle est dans une
forme remarquable avec civet cette fois
le mot civet et au civil c'est donc le
mot qui est pour vous et moselle vous
donnez votre prénom en jouer à n'y a ni
à vous rivet vive dive bouteille stop
viry je n'ai rien dit il
aube alors là je vois pas davis vit ce
vide vide vie de weeds vite
adjectif vie de marche
qu'est ce qu'il ya là soleil vite vite
si on transpose là qu'il sait on a gagné
on néglige ni un bravo bravo aux
compliments vous allez ça comprend
également à votre crédit c'est bien
intéressant il vient bien on dire vous
avez les candidats on continue on
continue bien gens continuent allons
continuer alors fait un autre avec loger
cette fois élogieux air loger gr bien on
continue c'est donc à vous un modèle
madame pendant alors allez-y louer louer
nous et nous et nous et vous et vous
voulez en voyant pas facile beauty voilà
à voter oui vas tu es beau matin par le
virus
oui les auteurs et son épouse vous ces
hôtesses alors des pops des sites et oui
mais si tu es oui parce qu'il y avait
des grands sinon si tu essaies bien site
avec un s et si tu jouais très bien soit
il conviendra en dida et bien jean
pierre je pense que vous avez des
candidats près de vous oui nous avons
notre ami hernandez qui est un champion
vous le savez des écoutes téléphoniques
oui d'ailleurs je te tiens à préciser
que actuellement est vraiment monsieur
rôle qu emeneya pelo et monsieur roches
van damme agacinski monsieur hollandaise
la télévision française se porte bien
vous me dire mais l'agent pied à vos
candidats sont prêtes volage et vient de
descendre maintenant dans la salle où
j'ai retrouvé un candidat qui avait
demandé le jeu du téléphone alors
qu'elle est d'abord vous présenter
xavier xavier bon alors xavier nous
sommes prêts girard barrineuf
conversation qui est au bout du fil
là nous allons servir dans quelques
instants avec un j'entends une seule et
je pense que je reste je pense que c'est
ton tour
gérard oui j'avais demandé une
communication a lancé du pcv alors oui
oui mademoiselle vous à mi temps rien
mais non je n'avais pas demandé les
quatre pattes les carpates
oui c'est ça ah oui merci allô allô
c'est vous je vous entends malin vous
avez l'air de rigoler là vous vous payez
une pinte de bon sens ah ah oui monsieur
alors comment vont les affaires bien va
forcément vous vous travaillez à 100%
vous un oui il faut dire que vous êtes
tout le temps sur le coup oui vous avez
des méthodes très incisive effectivement
fera rêver oui qu'est ce que vous me
dites oui oui oui vous préparer un
numéro 2 de claquettes à nom de
plaquettes de plaquettes sanguines
ah oui c'est très drôle mais c'est dur
oui oui c'est ça oui oui j'espère que
vous n'alliez pas vous mettre au pieu je
sais ça vous vexe non c'était une blague
comme ça en rigolant oui oui oh non je
vous en prie à aussonne france a nommé
no longer le temps j'ai le temps vous
pouvez aller ouvrir
merci les charbons et charmant qui
c'était c'était le facteur le facteur
rhésus donc vu non non non non dans
chacun fait comme il veut
oui oui oui oui danse et l'humour
mordant oui c'est servi écoutez monsieur
le comte je voulais c'est parce que j'ai
j'ai préparé à déjeuner vous j'ai fait
un potage de cerfeuil n'ont pas de
cercueil de serre feng a potage de terre
feuilles we had de l'aïoli à vous
n'aimez pas vous n'aimez pas ah non non
non non non je ne veux excuser moi je
n'irai pas vous voir non non non là pour
tout avant d'y revenir
c'est ça avant monsieur le comte c'est
ça mes amitiés avocat dan
voilà bien bravo bravo à gérard un
relais pour ce très beau coup de
téléphone
je pense jean piat qu'on n'aura pas de
difficulté à découvrir le correspondant
a alors xavier son pire si vous ne
trouvez pas city par monsieur dit le
vampire le talent et qu'il faudrait
peut-être préciser le cas leurs pattes
oui mais lequel est lequel dans la cave
juin aka monsieur le plus grand plus
beau renonce par un d le beau-frère de
nosferatu
plaît pas alors une fois de foire accula
voilà c'est bien messi avait déjà trouvé
d'empiré dracula la même d'engagement
droit parole vous allez gagner 50 francs
c'est très important très intéressant
alors maintenant je pense qu'il est
temps pour nous de jouer à
l'électronique au électronique au sheikh
harold avec un candidat qui va arriver
maintenant sur scène un plot dit par le
public
on va se tourner un petit peu voilà
alors je rappelle que vous allez gagner
100 francs par bonnes réponses
d'accord vous ne pouvez vous arrêter au
bout de la cinquième et il faut pas
revenir sur la lettre car vous auriez
tout perdu d'accord donnez votre nom
votre prénom
au bénin le gamer alors robert on va se
tourner un petit peu vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose dont je travaille
aux ptt un contribuer à côté voilà vous
travaillez au ptt verser bien maître
capello est prêt oui
white ra prenait trois adjectifs cette
lettre définition qui a de la sévérité
dans ses principes et de la gravité dans
son caractère comme à rome des posters
oui naître des noms communs encore cette
lettre locale en planches ou bien maison
en mauvais état peu solides ou peu
confortable drac
oui
lettre c si l'être l'an de vigne ou
variétés de vigne si ce n'est pas très
fin lettres des verbes du premier groupe
en huile est
voici la définition je dis bien vu
naître apprécié par le goût les qualités
d'un aliment solide ou liquide ou
populairement subir de mauvais
traitements
déguster à misano messieurs 1
d'accord c'est un nom commun
six lettres définition étendue indéfinie
qui contient et entourent tous les
objets ou bien étendu limitée intervalle
d'un point à un autre espace bravo
messieurs répondu sauf absolument alors
que chez que faites vous on fait un
petit flocon
oui parce que je pense que j'ai fait un
très beau parcours alors vous pouvez
tout de même tenté un on applaudit
monsieur grand don d'irriter m
maintenant on est où j'ai joué
excusez moi j'en ai deux wef et pour
cause donc j'ai est un nom commun de
cinq lettres que vous allez entendre
voici je dis bien cinq lettres gras nul
obtenu par le fractionnement des grains
lors du broyage et céréales synonyme
surtout synonyme de semoule farine fine
et très pur synonyme de semoule ou bien
faire in fine et très pur provenant de
nevio voilà
on mange ici j'ai produit un brouillon
cas en vous et vous continuez vous
arrêtez monsieur une fois encore petit
fois vous avez raison on ne sait pas
très bien
venez voir mode une syllabe
ça vient du pays d'harold qu'est les
gosses à des rires il a deviné catelet
tralala j'y cours des écossais en kilt
oui vous ne verrez bientôt un kilt
peut-être ses pattes à l'époque je sais
qu'à fait vous vous continuez toujours
c'est un jeu et ont pu ainsi vous
n'aurez vous l'aurez je l'espère que
cinq lettres nos propres employés comme
nom commun anciennes monnaies d'or
française valant 24 livres ou pièces
d'or française de 20 francs imploser
napoléon louis dit monsieur m continue
la interview que faites vous je crois
que je vais m'arrêter là m n'est pas
loin monsieur laura monsieur fait ce
qu'il veut mettre un registre l effort
monsieur et oui pas très bien monsieur
bravo vous vous arrêtez on va vous
applaudir c'est tout à fait remarquable
non monsieur vous avez gagné 800 francs
félicitations plus le sac de voyage de
faire 3 voilà et les applaudissements du
public
alors mon cher
encore un qui dit mieux eh bien on me
fait signe malheureusement que non mon
cher jean pierre et oui mais c'est pas
grave les enfants nous aurons l'occasion
de faire d'autres qui dit mieux nous
allons dire au revoir et remercie
d'abord le télégramme de brest dire au
revoir à tous vos invités c'est à dire
notre ami lionel roesch mal ça fait 15
ans qu'ils génèrent
m habré nouveau gago et bravo à guingamp
évidemment et sans plus tarder nous
allons demander à notre ami jean pierre
descombes ce qu'ils nous proposent pour
terminer ce jeu de l'inter